[Music]
here in the slovenian capital the eu has
helped fund a green retrofit for dozens
of public buildings
the program has slashed both co2
emissions and energy costs we have done
it with all our buildings
or our kindergartens swimming pools
schools
and of course city administration
buildings
the financial impact is more than 40
percent of energy savings
the european parliament wants to see
more projects like this
it's overhauling energy efficiency rules
targeting high consumption sectors like
heating and cooling industry and data
centers
the public sector is expected to lead
the way in greening infrastructure and
buildings like schools and hospitals
the commission has proposed member
states cut energy use 36 by 2030
parliament wants a binding target of 40
the greenest energy is the energy that
you don't use
so this is why energy efficiency is is
vital in the climate therefore if we had
100 renewable energy you could say that
it didn't matter so much how much energy
we used but unfortunately that's not the
case we have coal and gas and oil in our
energy mix
the revised energy efficiency directive
is part of europe's commitment to cut
greenhouse gas emissions 55 by 2030 and
become the first carbon neutral
continent by 2050
it's also a key step in tackling energy
poverty and reducing dependence on
russian fossil fuels
[Music]
you